[Music]
did our favorite Disney Princess really
say that we don't think so and the
problem is that you haven't been singing
the correct lyrics of your favorite song
if you love Disney songs as much as we
do don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up today we
are showing you 20 funniest misheard
Disney lyrics the circle of life there
is no way you can deny it you didn't
understand the lyrics either while
listening to the song many fans of The
Lion King heard things like pink pajamas
penguins on the bottom instead of
ingonyama negative a lot that's not
really a surprise during the beginning
others heard nah it's in Kenya mama the
Chihuahua such a ghoul when you're a mom
by the way they are actually singing
something in this song the words are
chanted in Zulu and main here comes a
lion father oh yes it's a lion
suddenly penguins sound more interesting
be prepared there is another song that
we misheard in the movie and this time
scar is the one who didn't pronounce
well in be prepared you can hear him
seeing a shiny new era is tiptoeing
nearer but many children were so scared
while watching this movie that they
understood something else that was a
shiny new mirror is tiptoeing nearer
after all it almost rhymes it's funny to
see that they understood the word
tiptoeing but not the word era or maybe
they were just trying to tell Skaar that
he should look in the mirror because he
has something on his face Hakuna Matata
it seems like the Lion King was one of
the most misunderstood movies but we
can't blame them
it's hard to make Lions sing and we are
impressed that we were able to
understand something but Timon and
Pumbaa might have some problems with
their pronunciation too we all remember
the song Hakuna Matata
and we're sorry we know that it's stuck
in your head right now but when you were
kids what did you sing right before
Hakuna Matata many people saying it's
our problem-free x' for a lot of ease
but the lyrics actually are it's our
problem-free philosophy oops the bare
necessities
let's meet other animals shall we we all
love our childhood friends in the Jungle
Book
but though it seems really fun to hang
out with them in the jungle we have to
admit that we wouldn't like to leave the
comfort of our own home
to live there this is why Balu decided
to teach us about the bare necessities
however some people might not understand
that right when the bear sang forget
about your worries and your strife some
people understood forget about your
worries and your stripes
what does Balu have against zebras
colors of the wind
here's another character who loves the
beauty of nature and sings about it in
her songs the Pocahontas won't be happy
to hear that John Smith didn't
understand what she was talking about
when she's saying have you ever heard
the wolf cry to the blue corn moon he
actually understood have you ever heard
the wolf cry to the lukewarm moon and by
the way Europeans really do have
problems with corn when fringe people
came to America they thought that they
were in India this is why they didn't
only call the Native Americans the
Indians but also called corn blood the
end which can be translated to Indian
wheat be our guest this fun fact
encouraged us to go to France and visit
Belle at her castle this is when we had
the chance to hear Lumiere sing the song
be our guest and surprisingly we did
understand the French lyrics but not the
English ones that's because the funny
character sings course-by-course and
many people understood horse pike horse
which doesn't sound really tasty by the
way can you imagine how empty the castle
is now that everyone turned back into
humans the next movie should be called
Beauty and the Beast
- the trip to Ikea Hawaiian
rollercoaster ride
we know that French sounds really
romantic but trying to flirt in Hawaii
might sound a little weirder that's
because we weren't supposed to
understand those lyrics but we did
anyway while listening to the song
you're supposed to hear then on my
surfboard out at sea but many people
heard
take off your shirt boy I want to see
then when they sing and if I had one
wish come true people heard daddy if I
had one wish he'd come true we have a
dirty mind now and we're not grown-ups
we just hope that kids didn't hear this
- hi ho people have a really dirty mind
they even managed to ruin one of the
most popular songs from Snow White in
the Seven Dwarfs
and we're pretty sure that no one would
have sung something like this in 1937
you probably remember the lyrics
heigh-ho heigh-ho it's home from work we
go but right before that the dwarfs were
also singing about what they did all day
they dig dig
dig dig dig dig dig but some grown-ups
actually understood the word big
followed by another word that starts
with the letter D if you don't
understand what we mean you're too young
for this poor unfortunate souls let's go
under the sea to see if things are more
appropriate down there
shall we but we think that we won't be
really lucky with the terrible Ursula
the octopus Inge they come flocking to
my cauldron but some people understood
that made her sound even more evil they
heard her say the f-word instead of the
word flocking and we have to admit that
these two words do look really similar
to come on kids should listen to that we
bet that a lot of parents were surprised
to hear them sing that song part of your
world we hope that Ariel is going to
make things better we can all agree that
part of your world was one of the best
songs from the movie but unfortunately
once again our ears ruined everything we
were supposed to hear bright young women
sick of swimmin ready to stand but
instead we heard pregnant women sick of
swimmin ready to stand
unfortunately we suggest that you don't
stand too much when you're pregnant if
you feel the need to move around and if
you can try going to the pool and swim
it's more relaxing for the belly a whole
new world Arielle managed to be part of
your world so let's find out what a
whole new world looks like we understood
that pronunciation is not the first
thing that comes to your mind when you
are travelling around the world on a
magic carpet so we can forgive these two
characters or maybe they just
intentionally change the lyrics you were
supposed to hear every turn a surprise
every moment red-letter but most of us
heard every turn a surprise every moment
gets better and we have to admit but
those lyrics are much better we prefer
this version of the song friends like me
did the voice actors come up with other
interesting song lyrics in Aladdin let's
see what they did with friends like me
they were actually supposed to say you
got a genie for a sharted affair the
reason why we probably didn't understand
the lyrics was because you are not
supposed to speak French in Arabia and
even French people would admit that they
never actually say Sasha Adair fair that
would explain why our ears couldn't
understand this and we ended up with
lyrics like you got a genie for he
charged and fell that doesn't make sense
but the original lyrics don't either
roustabouts
kids don't even understand the title of
the song it's not a surprise that they
don't understand the lyrics either in
case you didn't know roustabouts
actually refer to an unskilled or casual
laborer we were supposed to hear want to
doze off get them clothes off but must
keep awake keep he keep he wait so we
were supposed to hear get them clothes
off anyway many people also understood
lock the nose off get them clothes off
pot has pizza wings have to pee have to
pees we just hope these lyrics will make
more sense than the live action of the
movie once upon a dream this is probably
the most beautiful song from the movie
but then we all wondered could we hear
that right is it really what they said
many people heard that look in your eyes
that's so familiar ugly did she really
say that her prince was ugly now we
understand why she just went to sleep
until he forgot about her that's not
what happened she actually said that
look in your eyes is so familiar a gleam
come on it makes much more sense and it
also rhymes with dream if you want to
hear a more modern version of that song
we suggest you listen to Lana's RA touch
the sky we want to listen to more modern
movies now and Merida is the first
Disney princess to be animated by Pixar
she is also the first princess who
didn't need a prince and we are really
happy about it
however some lyrics make us think
otherwise that's because many of us
heard chase the wind and touch the sky
when listening to the song but she kept
repeating this over and over again but
she was actually singing to chase the
wind and touch the sky come on guys
that's the title of the song how can we
miss this I've got a dream here's
another Disney Princess animated by
Pixar and don't tell the others but she
was probably our favorites and if we had
a dream we would like to date Flynn
Rider but what do other people dream
about in I've got a dream with the men
at the bar sing call us brutal sick
sadistic and we really don't understand
why but many people actually heard call
us brutal saints of sydney these people
don't really look like saints but this
movie also taught us that we can't judge
or maybe that's just how things are in
Australia I see the lights later in the
movie Tangled
the thief turned out to be a true Prince
Charming when he made Rapunzel's dream
come true this is when she started
singing standing here
it's also clear I'm where I'm meant to
pee what did she really say that okay
some people do pee in lakes and no one
notices but that's not very romantic
mostly when your prince is watching but
we understand why she would suddenly
need to pee when there is so much water
around anyway you probably guess that
Rapunzel just wanted to sing that's
where I'm meant to be do you want to
build a snowman we're sorry this song is
stuck in your head right now but at
least we still love singing it why not
use it to actually ask your sister to
build a snowman
however just make sure that you sing the
right lyrics that's because some people
understood do you want to build a
snowman it's only gonna be a snowman but
then other people understood do you want
to build a snowman it doesn't have to be
a snowman so which one is right that's
some kind of Mandela effects we don't
know what you guessed but the right
answer is the second one love is an open
door
villains should really make sure that
they watch their language when they are
part of a kids movie actually we didn't
know that Hans was evil at the beginning
of the movie but that would have been a
great way to guess it in love is an open
door han sang but with you I found my
place but some grown-ups actually heard
that the word found was replaced by
another word that starts with F
obviously it wouldn't make sense but we
kept watching it over and over again
okay we actually watched it over and
over again just because we loved it but
we still heard that every time I'll make
a man out of you so what was the
funniest misheard lyric on this list
it's from the movie Mulan and we
actually chose this one because we would
like it to be true we were supposed to
hear
with all the force of a great typhoon
but we actually heard with all the force
of a great typhoon and we have to admit
that eating does make us stronger so
that totally makes sense is there any
other lyric that you misheard don't be
shy to answer in the comment section
down below
we'd love to hear what you think and
that's it for 20 funniest misheard
Disney lyrics for more stories like this
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up thanks
for watching and see you next time
[Music]